[Music]
and Kate popped the question why you
almost blessed and sponge busted up
brother
that's a bit of a step above I I love JK
more than kpop I like kpop to know have
you guys heard of a doc - gonzo haha
that's not kpop not like Jo hip hop yeah
that's K rap right
it is pretty dope he hasn't always I
went to Baltimore who's that one crew
that did that one thing with a Japanese
crew they did the collabo and it is ma
ma ma I'll keep faith oh I like that
I'll do this on same hob and okay rapper
hip-hop it's hot it's cool I just think
like I don't want to say anything bad
about it you know like Korean version
not Korean on the ring I love I think
like Korean people are like I'm a
hip-hop game in Asia like in terms of
like Asian people we're [ __ ] right
there yeah it's just like to think yeah
like is the fact that they kind of like
take away from my hip-hop culture
without paying their due respect you
don't mean because they're not run a
screen it's like like I seen it like
they got cornrows grilled like it's
super like sweet as an American and then
I wish I grew up in a black community
it's kind of like King bro ah you know I
mean but I don't know if black people
are saying about it who the [ __ ] you
think though it is it's just a little
weird - is like the Japanese lowriders
yeah hey cholo yeah yeah you're right
I'm saying I think it's more like a lot
of lines of I like authenticity to a
certain extent like you could do that
type of music but keep it really who you
are like it's moving them because we
don't they see it on TV or they start
their life I want that give me a girl
give me some brave I see so it's kind of
like clown makeup to me I love the
musical I understand because like I have
friends I feel exactly the same way you
do like so I like the music I think it's
dope like you talk about like like their
flow their cadence it's there you know
what I mean but I just don't
you're [ __ ] a culture biting too much
I see it's okay they do a good job and
then black people are cool with it
that's all that matters I don't say like
it was I focus and I'm like well Who am
I to say I just kind of like to have to
to see of it whatever a kpop superstar
was caught vaping liquid marijuana and
overdoses on tranquilizers what nah how
unchanged for Korean yeah if you smoke a
weed in a Korea that's a you better
[ __ ] run back to run away to America
didn't jay Park get kicked out of Korea
because of smoking the marijuana now
there was some like drama about it so he
basically put out a he put out this
statement where he was like he was a
part of this group 2 a.m. 2 p.m. for ppm
champion 2 p.m.
early-bird he put out the statement
basically saying like people
misinterpreted him talking like [ __ ]
about like Korean rappers but he wasn't
saying that is that what he was saying
was people are giving me respect like
I'm a dope rapper but I honestly think
I'm pretty mediocre and they were like
saying that he was like culture bashing
or whatever whatnot I think I think
that's what it was from what I remember
I thought it was him just talking [ __ ]
about Korea being like being sane like
he hates it here it doesn't feel like no
he wasn't saying that what he was saying
was kind of like he people are saying
that he's like the dope like the dope
it's like one of the greatest is like
I'm not so it kind of came off as him
like bashing like Korea and every I
wasn't he wasn't some weed scandal
happening with him I don't know about
that I know g-dragon kind of I don't
think he got in trouble for it though
yeah and if you'd like to do was just
talking he was very unhappy with his
state like being in Korean stuff but he
was just kind of like expressing how I
felt on a blog but you know like Korean
fans too like these quote-unquote
medicine as they call him they're
[ __ ] insane like they take one thing
and they let us spin out of control so
he got a little bit crucified for it but
they do still one you can't say nothing
about Korea now cuz Korea number one can
we start a kpop Ricky called
seaweed company the three of us yeah
yeah so this k-pop stars name is top 40
Opie Franz the group Oh Big Bang so here
you got caught being involved with
marijuana smoking so what happened was
there was this female friend was also a
kpop trainee like she's training to be a
part of a k-pop group so apparently she
got caught for smoking marijuana and
then when the police were interrogating
her
asking her questions she brought up this
dude's name oh you rat map [ __ ] haha
ratted him out so then that's when the
police went to him and then they got a
hair follicle sample which has you know
a bleach in it and colors yes but it can
also store information of like any drug
uses for like the past three I could get
your hair I over there this is Mack the
Med the Naaman so they did find THC in
his hair follicles yeah he'd been
smoking that [ __ ] oh you gonna get his
hands chopped off now so when he got
caught he was already he was serving
time because every Korean citizen needs
to serve time in the army all not as of
now anymore because he got dismissed but
at that time when he got caught she was
doing his military service so then that
was kind of like what the hell they came
in the military and he got caught
smoking marijuana which is like a huge
deal in South Korea because they're
saying that you can get a five-year
sentence or be fined $45,000 for smoking
we yeah yeah but then how do they even
prove that he smoked weed just oh I mean
like what if you're in a room and some
lowlife Americans oh those guys they
were smoking weed inside the room but
you guys were recording the next hit
album but you had to be in the room with
these sinful American I think there was
an eyewitness meld it and you go home
and you [ __ ] breathe in the THC and
it came into your hair
three years ago it happened it's so
funny with like Korea and like there's
like weed laws but they're [ __ ]
taking drugs that's all of Asia I think
like you could you [ __ ] go to jail in
all of Asia for getting caught with weed
but they promote let's drink every night
with our co-workers and get [ __ ]
wasted yeah I don't see what the
difference is not a big fan of the
drunkenness they're treating weed like
it's [ __ ] heroin
so apparently he smokes marijuana three
times in his home in Seoul Korea and so
he after this all came out he ended up
writing a handwritten apology letters do
yeah I'm so sorry I was supposed to be
like a role model but actually I'm nah
yeah it's pretty much what it says I
don't know any musician that doesn't do
drugs though I made it my fans so
dissipated don't do drugs on lil yachty
doesn't smoke for drink at all at all
that bad I'm not like Andre 3000 Oh
probably yes I know that that chance of
rep reading so nobody do that's dope
though like I really appreciate and
they're open about it too because I
think like in that community like back
in the day if you didn't smoke or drink
you because you'll push you're a little
[ __ ] yeah so you don't close I think it
may be the laws are a little bit
unrealistic comment on musicians do
drugs so [ __ ] it I smoked weed what's
new in the musician but if there are
people that don't and I guess it is
realistic but kpop is like to me is like
um it's pop it's like Disney it's like
clean but they're hella coke cans no but
that's what we know right but but it's
kind of like at the height of you know
Britney Spears career or whatever like
if they were caught doing coke I feel
like it would be a scandal here to true
it wouldn't be as bad because you kind
of expect American Hollywood people to
just be drugged up I'm pretty sure to
like when they come to the stage some
person is smoking something yeah the
people in Korea they do smoke but they
have to be a lot more secretive about it
oh yeah that's just like Americans that
don't even smoke but when they go to
Amsterdam she'll still be like really
I'll just mess around it's cool here and
they don't want to come back to the
states and always talking on mark less
than a day after the charges top was
found unconscious and so apparently he
allegedly overdosed on benzodiazepine
which is aka xanax or valium so it's
again like I'm sorry he was so like
freaking out that he
take all those anxiety pills and then he
fainted it looks like it looks like he
he overdosed yeah because of the
strategies to us do you know how many
groupies you can have just massaging you
relaxing you and [ __ ] paint your
toenails that's a way better way to
relax than [ __ ] taking xanax yeah and
then like apparently a lot of media
outlets and the police themselves were
saying that he's fine he's just in deep
sleep everyone but just has one down
she's already like foaming at the mouth
yeah but then the his books using all
the results if mom came out and like
carefully was saying like this fuse our
wrongful reports like this is not true
my son is in serious he's on ginseng you
guys talking about no she's like my son
is unconscious she wasn't responding he
had really low oxygen levels in his
blood
let's try to stay away that's why we put
the system yeah I can't stay pale trying
to stay Pia I must say pretty even when
I'm knocked out it's my good angle
Thursday incentive take a photo like
this low level of oxygen like you should
be it can cause like a lot of brain
damage course so that's what his mom is
distress sucks she's really worried
right now
maybe you should be vaping oxygen this
day well yeah you thought he has an
oxygen mask I don't know you could bake
xanax no no no you baby marijuana and
then he took anti example pills because
of this whole ordeal overdose so I
thought but the we would have done if
I'm home well I think you should just
[ __ ] just take advantage you busy
that goes to show that he should have
just had the weed not these [ __ ]
pills yeah but we would have just
chilled them out they're legal pills to
I know these [ __ ] legal pills use
like bout a diet [ __ ] on the week nope
Korea you got to change up your laws man
get with the program that sucks I wonder
how much [ __ ] you must be going through
to like have to feel like you need to
take all these drugs just and they can
feel normal
yeah I mean he's facing jail time and
like all of this so they're saying
that's in the past like that one number
that you mentioned earlier that you
drive excuse in the same group we have
so apparently their label YG
Entertainment they
had some sort of connections with the
government so they were able to kind of
like hush-hush that whole thing it's
called corruption because kpop brings on
so much money into the nation exactly so
then but now that they don't have those
ties anymore to the president now that's
why he's so stuck if he doesn't have
that like safety blanket oh yeah because
like the president is like so corruption
all over the place oh what the [ __ ] is
going on because there's some drama in
the politics - yeah it's like career so
strict about weed like me personally I
don't I don't have anything against me I
just like like how I feel about we just
how I feel about drinking you know I
mean yeah I don't like things that make
that people use to help them feel normal
constantly and that's it's not an
against thing I don't like it
you know yeah so it's not a moral thing
it's just like it's a preference for me
like if you have to constantly smoke to
make you feel like this then I'm like I
don't really like it that's why I say
they don't like me and drinking I get
people who always drink just to have fun
it's like you can't have everything
I just think that people shouldn't treat
substances as a criminal behavior yeah
so going sent to jail and all that [ __ ]
these are people that need help if
you're abusing a substance they need
help
so waste of our money right so they need
counseling they need emotional support
they need something else right and the
way that they treat drinking is like
they encourage it this is a majority of
Asian cultures most people aren't
alcoholics but when they go into the
workforce they start to become
alcoholics and they abuse alcohol and
stuff like that but there's no programs
really or no social like like what do
you call it departments or anything
helping out people that have alcohol
problems but with me they treat it as a
criminal you know they treat it as like
it's it's a criminal act
you smoking some weed and you're you're
like a scumbag yeah you're [ __ ] to
society it's like what those fun yeah
it's really cuz like even I have a
relative who that was visiting from
Korea and when he came here we were
having dinner and the place didn't have
a liquor license right and so we were
eating and he was let me get a like a
couple bars of soldiers or we don't have
a liquor
we can serve you and he's like what do
you mean is you'll have any money look
at it how much will to eat how much to
eat [ __ ] I just said that like
befuddled looks like you you can't eat
if you're not drinking and then I looked
I went back I was like every time he ate
with me he was working alcohol that's
what he's used to yet he can't function
without alcohol
this [ __ ] walked two blocks went
to a liquor store got two bottle of soju
went up to the waitress and Sheila well
I can't serve it to here so Hugh so what
this will did he dumped out the water
out of the canteen and he put the soda
bottles into the water canteen and he
just drank two bottles to himself damn
that's a like I can't eat rice without
cigarettes yeah like to buy fittings
that no smoking in this restaurant how
about you then career like you smoke you
drink you eat it's like that it's like a
three-way trifecta smoking and drinking
is like [ __ ] water with your meal
actually it did it was weird like what
he didn't get his alcohol he was like I
think the most like he wants to blog to
buy alcohol so he can put it into a
water thing come on now that's a problem
yeah restaurant didn't have napkins or
something
I'm appalled yeah so as of now or the
last I heard topic still unconscious so
we have seemed like they were
speculating like oh because of all of
this like he took those drugs commit
suicide things like that you know I hope
the people of Korea use this as an
opportunity to change and do difference
in their country I'm gonna say this and
they're going to send assassins to me
but I'll go foot bring it but it's also
like how they how they idolize their
stars and also how they treat their
talent you know talent in my Korea if
you guys don't know they're slaves
yeah the [ __ ] slaves man like these
like kpop training camps or hardcore you
know if you're a fan out daily oh that's
not true they live in the light shut the
[ __ ] up I'm Korean and I'm also an
entertainment and we know people that
work in the Korean entertainment
industry and what they had to go through
exactly so when you see like
systematically a lot of these k-pop
stars who are losing their [ __ ] mind
and you don't look at it like it's a
problem and then we're the crazy ones
for saying it but you should really
think about that too like there's like
back in the day - if a kpop star would
start dating somebody that girl that
they were dating get death threats every
day like get the [ __ ] I will find y'all
[ __ ] murder yes my man so they
wouldn't date openly publicly because
they were afraid of for the people that
they were with so yeah I think like one
dude lost like half of his fanbase once
he came out that he has a girlfriend and
you're like oh how dare you do this to
us you know like I thought like we were
all meant for you and ball oh yeah it's
like we're doing these like you gonna
you going to get with 30,000 girls yes
I'm [ __ ] am I suppose to [ __ ]
myself to now let me go back how did
that we'll stay still pale training in
the Sun all day
sunscreen bro remember we solve those
kpop pretty cops oh yeah I'm pretty good
because they had to do like a military
service out there so we just saw some
k-pop boys just like in cop uniform and
yeah actually the entire band Big Bang
they all have to serve military times
but do indoor bootcamp
no but due to their age they have to do
it at separate time so this entire group
is on a hiatus a minimum of four years
because they all have to do military
service four year military's well they
have to do it separately it's only used
to be four years it's not two years okay
yeah that's I remember so back in the
day when my dad did it it was four years
but for three I forgot about the hard
car so I think Korea too for a country
has like the largest standing military I
can't imagine that's what throwing a
grenade huge missile Mariano and then
this is the training that ratted them
out what a bit [ __ ] Jezebel wait go
back
how the [ __ ] does she look like Asian
librarian to
softcore porn how the [ __ ] did that
happen no signal for me to change this
picture to hope you guys enjoyed that
video if you did a really cool way to
communicate that to us and for you to
never miss another video is by
subscribing so click on that little
subscribe button and you'll never miss
an episode for the next episode click
right up here